ايون قليله تفصلنا عن الانتخابات النصفيه
الاكثر الشرسه منذ عقود في الولايات
المتحده بالنسبه للديمقراطيين على خساره
ليست سيئه في كل الاحوال وتحديدا بالنسبه
للجيل الجديد في الحزب الصعود السلم نحو
ادوار القياده الاعلام الامريكيه تحدث ان
الخساره ستعني اعتزال الجيل المخضرم وعلى
راسهم رئيسه مجلس النواب نانسي الاثنين
والثمانين عاما للعوده الى ارض اجدادها
عبر منصبن اديب رومانسيه شاغره
اما الجمهوريون الفوز وقد ان يرشح كافه
شريحه على الاخرى ايضا واستنقسامه حول
عددا من الملفات مثل حجم الدعم المناسب
لاوكرانيا وتزوير نتيجه انتخابات الرئاسه
الاخيره وتحول من جمهوريه
كيف ما يقرب من نصف الجمهوريين الذين
يترشحون لمنصب الفيدرالي او على مستوى
الولايه يتفقون مع الرئيس السابق ترامب ان
الرئاسه سرقت منه لكن رغم كل هذا هناك
معركه جانبيه تعتبر الاهم رئاسيه وليست
نسقيه بين الرئيس الحالي
وسلفيه دونالد ترامب بالنسبه لترامب تمثل
الوجوه الجمهوريه التي راها عليها مؤشرا
على حجمها نفوذه في الحرب نجاحهم سيقطعوا
اي شكوكوك حوله هويه المرشح الرئاسي
الجمهوريه بعد عامين اما بعد ان الذي
انخفضت شعبيته خلال عامين من الدعم
التشريعي لمشاريع قوانينه ستعني السيطره
الجمهوريه على الكونغرس ان يقضي ما تبقى
من ولايته مكبله اليدين مواجهات الشرعيه
اقرب للخساره التحقيقات حول ملفات العده
وعلى راسها
اهي هنتر
تفاؤل والثقه بالفوز باغلبيه قويه في مجلس
النواب في الانتخابات النصفيه بعد ايام
وهناك مؤشرات على زياده مقاعدهم في مجلس
الشيوخ موقع 5308 كان يظهر ان
الديمقراطيين سيحافظون على غالبيات ضئيله
في مجلس الشيوخ لكن الموقع بدا منذ ايام
يرجح احتماليه فوز الجمهوريين باكثر مقاعد
المجلس ووصلت نسبه الاحتمال الى اربعه54%
اما احتمال الفوز الجمهوريين باكثريات
مقاعد مجلس النواب فارتفع الى اربعه و80%
الاسباب عديده وعلى سبيل المثال للحصر لان
حزب الرئيس يخسر في الانتخابات النصفيه
اضافه الى التضخم وارتفاع نسبه الجرائم